[Applause]
i'm lucky to be here right now
really i almost drowned in hawaii
hundred percent okay i thought there was
like a hit on you or something no
i almost drowned bro the the water bro
i was in the water okay i don't know if
that that's where you drown
the ocean amid the ocean okay i'm in
lanai hawaii right small
island hawaii remember i told you that
was the one island that doesn't have
surf
right yeah and i was like [ __ ] how i
picked the vacation on the one place it
doesn't have surf i love surfing right
i mean i love serving so much i went to
the [ __ ] this surf
park in waco texas instead of seeing
chappelle and
uh joe rogan i drove two hours to go
surfing waco was a wild place waco
texas that's where the cult was that's
where the cult was yeah bailly
raping everybody son but outside of that
part of it this
surf pool is absolutely amazing i got to
start with these guys they're incredible
and uh but what not real they were
amazing though
outside of the cult outside the cult and
like the shooting whatever happened
there the bsr
surf camp bro you guys got to go that's
just absolutely amazing perfect swell
thank you all so much for having me it
was unbelievable
um i'm at lanai okay
i go surf the first day historic waves
they'll never get waves like this
nobody they nobody they've never seen
waves like this right
for years you go you go look on youtube
right now surf in the lanai the videos
are from 2012
2013. there's no waves they've never
everywhere
it's like they never said five years ago
when they have years ago
these are two sides of every story
there's a lot for hawaii to go without
waves
we're not talking about like when it
snows in florida we're talking about the
surf capital of the world
right never snows in florida you look up
snow on florida's videos from like
like 2012 19. what is the future the
indian nationalist might have a point
okay
okay so i'm there right i surf the first
day
i get a board somehow i finagle aboard
just to let you guys know
everything was stopping me from surfing
there i called the hotel in advance i
was like hey can i surf there they're
like no it's illegal
to bring a board into the ocean it's a
marine wildlife preserve and we don't
allow surfing
i go that's weird i started asking
different people island how do i get a
board finally i find a way to get a
board
board meets me at the hotel hang out
with my girl
i can't ditch her the second i get to
the island so we fake go to the pool for
a minute
i'm in 30 minutes she we get the fill in
i go take the board in i surf this wave
it's the softest easiest wave in the
world after the takeoff
the takeoff is right over reef and rocks
so once you get up you're good and it's
the easiest ride
but getting up you're right on you see
the coral heads bubbling in front of you
as you're paddling into the wave
first day surf the way you're talking to
me is the way
you probably felt when i was talking
about the india farmer thing you're just
like
once we start treating farmers with
respect okay i stand with schultz yo
what do they form out there yeah that's
what i'm talking about yeah
you're gonna take that ipad to let you
farm over there china
but anyway so first day surf is fine i
survived second day
surf fine i survived yeah i've started
to have this weird fear
yeah and i think this fear is somewhat a
function
of like uh there's almost like a
function
of like a guilt in success
where i'm go am i biting off too much
right like
i i took a small plane to get to the
lanai thing and i'm like am i asking for
too much
is god gonna smite me because i couldn't
just stay
home you say small you mean private i
did take pride again oh my god
it is like this are you trying to unflex
for us no i'm just because
it didn't even make sense like i said a
shitty plane and i was like am i doing
too much
it wasn't completely private there was
someone else staying at the resort that
i was really bummed about but yeah
and the resort provides i didn't have to
pay for anything at all but i made it
look like that on the ground yeah i mean
shout out to the farmers
i make [ __ ] look like i know what i'm
talking about so
[Applause]
let me flex and god was like oh work you
go surf we'll go see about that
so third day i go in the water and i'm
starting i've had this feeling
a couple times even on the trip like we
were on a cliff and i was looking over
the cliff and i'm like
yo do you should you chill out a little
bit like why are you pushing it like
you've been given so much like god or
the universe whatever it is has been so
great to you why do you need to go extra
what are you doing like is that
disrespectful i don't know why i'm
having these feelings you do this all
the time
but lately it's been happening a lot now
i get it right does that make sense a
little bit
throughout the whole like the last all
these months any time some bad [ __ ]
would happen
you just look at the ground like kick
some [ __ ] on the ground go
what does it mean yes
what's the meaning of all this what do
you mean like i have a book
mark okay i'm still searching for the
book some bad [ __ ] has ah what's the
point
yeah they don't talk about private
planes and corinthians
okay i'm still trying to figure it all
out
okay so third day that's the white boy
[ __ ] man
al third day we go back in the water
right yeah
this is historic surf but here's the
amazing amazing thing
people are so unprepared for surf on the
island inside a big surf island i'm
surfing historic
hawaiian surf alone five people tops so
what i was doing was i was waiting for
the locals shout out to the locals that
were able there took me out
ben brian they were great i would watch
them they were on the takeoff spot and i
would say a little bit to the right away
from the rocks
so i was like they really know how to
take off in a crazy spot if i'm a little
away from them i'll be obviously take
off is what do you
start the surface exactly yeah when you
paddle into the waves okay right
so i go the third day it's literally
one person out in me and the other guy's
a tourist as well he's at the hotel
so neither of us know where the take-off
spot is so we're just guessing
a huge set comes in right
i go to paddle for the wave i pop up
i get to my feet the board's a little
wobbly the wave really jacks up and i
fall
and since i know the rocks are beneath
me i pancake
instead of going straight in i go out as
much as i can i start tumbling
everything's fine
right all right the wave washes me
around
i paddle up to the surface as my hands
breach the surface
i blow out my air natural reaction right
you know you're about to breach
these your hands are above the water i
blow out my air
and then i stop what the [ __ ] i paddle
again
i stop my leash will not let me go
the leash had wrapped around the coral
and the board
had me locked under the water i'm
paddling
i'm [ __ ] kicking i'm kicking you saw
my foot was all black and blue i posted
that picture i'm kicking the reef the
reef is scraping up the bottom of my
feet
i'm literally in that moment going holy
[ __ ]
is this is this it yeah keep in mind i
blew out the air yeah you
you're oxygen-less i take a breath
because i have no more air left of water
i thought that's when you die i thought
it's you take the breath of water
and then you're dead i swear to god in
this moment
i went from panic to like game time and
everything calmed down and it got
pinpoint
there was one thing that i had to do and
focus on and i remember when i was
surfing in waco
one of the guys there all this is
happening in like a fraction of a second
this guy eric geiselmann shot to him
said once he was surfing in tahiti he
got slammed and his board got wrapped
around the coral
and he tried to grab his leash by
bending at the waist down to get it but
he couldn't
so he did is he bent his knees up to him
to grab the leash like for whatever
reason it was easier or stronger oh
that's the part i was missing you
couldn't i was like why can't you just
i thought you were just trying to kick
the board for you no i was trying to
just get up i didn't even realize
you can't even come down to take the
leash off exactly right why
and why can't you do that i at first i
didn't know i just
heard it tug i felt it tug and then in
that moment
i was like oh [ __ ] so i'm about to go
how do i get this leash off and then i
remembered the story he was telling me
where he bent the legs up
right and in that moment nowhere i just
breathe water
everything gets pinpoint like there's
one thing it's game time
that's the only way i can describe it
like it was it was weirdly the most
terrifying and empowering thing has ever
happened in my life that like when your
your life's about to turn off
yeah that in that moment
you actually have some calm to get it
done like you have a couple more seconds
to like get yourself out of this
predicament and i remember i bent
uh bent my legs up and as i bent my legs
up i grabbed the leash
the leash and the board pop up and i
breached the surface
[Music]
bro terrifying that's wild terrifying
and what do you do after that you just
float on in and i went back out
deserve more yeah because if i didn't go
back out i have a fear for the rest of
my life
so i went back out bleeding out of my
[ __ ] foot and i got like you know a
few more waves and then i went back in
that was so funny it's just like he's
telling me the story and i just
it's just in my head white people [ __ ]
like the moment you saw the reef and the
dangerousness like
go surfing another time so no no no no
haven't
because if you weren't here i couldn't
say it verbally
but i was dumb i was stupid why was that
dumb for
for chasing my dream
you know what i'm saying like all these
farmers that many drinks these farmers
wanted
to farm bro that's all they want is the
farm to make a living
all i want to do is no money surfing
there's no living surface that's true
you can't have that many dreams i make
almost as much as they do
i'm gonna be honest honestly the amount
of money a farmer makes in india i'd
probably make a bottle i know that's why
you need some minimum support surface
pricing
yo your boy had to get that wiki on bro
i had to get that wiki
i'm glad you're here me too i'm gonna be
honest at the beginning that story you
said you almost drowned i was like
everybody almost drowned at some point
but that [ __ ] was real when i breathed
in the water that [ __ ] was crazy
yeah that was a crazy ass feeling bro
and then you're just stuck down there
that's why i was like oh [ __ ] the board
is just holding you down
i pull up like this and i go to take the
breath because i'm just timing i'm not
assuming my leg is
is caught and as i blow the air out and
as i go to take the breath in i'm still
under the water and i go
i go oh [ __ ] so how many breaths do you
think one get you only get one water
breath
i don't know maybe some people get zero
i must have had a little bit more oxygen
in my lungs or else i'd be dead
but uh i mean i was crazy i didn't take
the water breath like
underwater breath you're swallowing
water that's a water breath
that's a water that's what happens bro
but i mean that you call it a water
breath it's called that
yeah yeah why don't you just say yo i
swallowed water
no it's not they just pay the farmers
more there's a lot of people just ask